all right I want to let you know before
we begin the episode a couple dates that
are rescheduled
these are rescheduled dates February
27th the sayers Ville New Jersey date
has now been moved and it is February
27th in Red Bank New Jersey at the Count
Basie or bassy Center for the Arts it's
going to be the Count Basie Center for
the dark arts that night but those
tickets go on sale Friday at 10 a.m.
Eastern Standard Time as well the next
night I will be in Oxon Hill Maryland at
the theater at MGM National Harbor that
is a rescheduled date and it is now on
February 28th Oxon Hill Maryland it's
back on so if you had tickets before
then you will still have tickets they
should be emailing you so you may want
to touch base with your email today's
guest is a young man we act we became
buddies on his podcast and and I don't
even like saying the word buddies
actually so I'm not gonna say it again
but I will say that this man is a unique
man and he's from the h3 podcast and and
he gots a new child him and his wife
ladies and gentlemen mr. Ethan and Klein
[Music]
are you been leaning out well thank you
that I've been on a feeding window which
is a funny way of saying intermediate
fasting intermediate intermediate
fasting I've got a reason I have Aston
sometimes intermittent intermittent
thank you I'm like I feel like a farm
animal I like the feeding window analogy
because it just sounds funny like I just
eat out of a trough for eight hours and
then go into fasting okay that oh yeah
there's some around your neck full of
nuts
yeah means yeah just a feeding bag
around my neck at all times I just I
feed between ten and six and then and
then I fast so it's good for me because
my urges to eat all the time
and so by putting that restriction on
myself I feel like it cuts down on a lot
of a late night snacking mmm extra meals
I'm all PM's yeah yeah extra meals eum's
make be mmm I used to say you grandma
never said that she - she do marmalade
let me come visit her for ten years at
one point in airline why you had beef
with your own grandma I didn't she had
beef with me I was too young I think to
have beef how was your how does your own
grandma have beef with you she had beef
with me she um there were some we had
some discrepancies at the house and then
she said I couldn't come visit tell me
what happened you're being obscure well
no she said I ate some candies at her
house and I didn't I don't know if I eat
them or not you're making this [ __ ] up
no not you you don't get this you don't
get banished from your gram of this war
you can use term disbarred if you want
your grandma disbarred you over
somewhere there's classics
that's called flooded rose I hear more
your background is tough it would that
that was won't probably one of the what
kind of candies oh and here's the thing
oh I don't always I know what it was it
was chocolate-covered cherries hmm and
your nerves it they made these good
cookies and I didn't get to have this
for a long time but ten years over some
as God's plan brah you know it gets oh
well well now that I know that that the
show is going what what were we talking
about cuz I was interested if we could
go take a step back yeah what were we
talking about barrel
bill burr you were talking about Oh
welcome to the bill burr recovery yeah I
went into therapy after that episode I'm
not even really I'm not even being
kidding I mean I was having a depressive
episode for a long time right and I had
these antidepressants next to my bed for
a long time and not taking them no I
hadn't decided to take them yet I was
hesitant yeah and after that episode
bill burr I came home and I that's when
I started taking in I pressed
antidepressants that I went to therapy
Wow it was soul-crushing and II was it
so consumed because you felt like as an
interviewer it was so crushing or just
like a zit on a human level like you
think do you know the levels where it
felt that it hits you right um
everything man my my fans were I don't
know a fan but audience were very harsh
as an interviewer I felt like a failure
it was just off it wasn't you know it
wasn't it didn't feel that bad but it
was the reaction the audience reaction
to it afterwards I mean I knew I had
goofed up and that it was a not the best
interview and I was such a big fan of
Bilborough obviously whoo yeah he's he's
a legend and you just in your mind have
high hopes that you'll be able to yeah I
get something good at it yeah there's
expectations yeah I like but that that
there was people making like video
essays about how what a terrible you
know interviewer I know really that's
that's YouTube style that's kind of
stuff I'm I'm somewhat used to but yeah
that just felt I just it felt like a
rock bottom for me because I was having
a hard time with the podcast and
interviews in general and that for me
was just kind of like the culmination of
a lot of oh like dress oh that's
interesting so it was like so in
hindsight though does it almost feel
like it was it was supposed to happen
like it was like oh I needed something
that you kind of made me look at stuff
or just gave me like a moment to reflect
well I definitely needed something to
push me because taking antidepressants
going to therapy was like the best
choice I ever made for me and my family
and professionally too I mean we had
everything better
really so I mean if it wasn't that it
would be something else but
but that was a little bit of somehow it
was part of a catalyst it was it was a
few night alignment yeah yeah it was it
was that and I had him on a second time
somewhere recently and it went great
so I'm happy to hear that yeah he
reached out he said he wanted to do it I
was like god bless dude let's go there's
like Fear Factor for me
round two yeah everyone in my life the
first time let's go and yeah that's
interesting yeah it was a yeah when he
came in here was a strange experience
man it was I don't know I just felt like
he was a different person not on
podcasts and he was on podcast it's
almost like but then also I didn't
really know him that great and so maybe
I just don't know how people are
that's true I I wonder if he listens to
these probably not oh I mean I doubt he
doesn't mean everybody's busy yeah he's
he doesn't care what we think about them
I listen to some of those murder things
you know where people get murdered some
guy walking into the woods in the Joshua
Tree and [ __ ] never came out and how
do you hear that there's a podcast I
like missing people or something do you
feel like that when you talk about Bill
burr like a missing person like oh I
felt like it was a couple minutes after
as I was just kind of wandering around
you know but I I don't know I just you
know I did not know him that good let me
ask you this when you guys ended I mean
it was it was clearly you knew it wasn't
going well during or was it when you
started the Reno I knew that there was
something uncomfortable I didn't know if
I didn't know I thought for a second
like maybe I was going crazy or always
like Vietnam you're getting in your head
you're what's going on well it's just an
uncomfortable most like oh well he and I
obviously there's only so much time that
we probably one of the reasons maybe we
don't talk that much is because we just
mind if I take these off no it's fine
it's because we shouldn't talk that much
you know
so I just thought here's a guy who is
very he's exactly what I thought when I
if I really would have looked at it oh
here's a guy who maybe this is exactly
the way he is onstage there's not a way
for her there's no real difference you
know it's just he's just rambling kind
of like if he's unhappy he's unhappy and
he you know eternally disgruntled bright
he's kind of uh you know guy who's kind
of fighting against his own probably ill
wills and [ __ ] looks like all of us are
in some weird ways but for him maybe
it's like a just a different battle and
also that he he likes to that he's the
center of attention a lot I think and so
it's he probably he might not be able to
really notice when how other people are
feeling or reacting that's kind of the
vibe that I got at the end and right so
the thing is that I think I feel like
most guests 99% of guests they're
they're more gracious you know they
won't take the opportunity if they see
you like are uncomfortable or you goofed
up or maybe you said like when he sees
an opening he will he like attacks yeah
you know what I mean and it's the same
way as comedies like I mean that's why
he's so good at Connie but like he he is
unlike anyone else I've ever interviewed
because the second time when I
interviewed him I really just like
talked as little as I possibly could
yeah and that and that was Bette the
bass but you you obviously have to
handle each interview differently but he
was unlike anyone I had ever interviewed
because yeah and I don't even really
interview he was one like it one like
why finish a sentence arias that time
because he is because he's not willing
to give you the benefit of the doubt you
know what I mean and he will he will
expose any chinks in her armor yeah cuz
for him that's comedy right right after
he's gonna make a moment out of it right
for me I'm like ah [ __ ] my fragile ego
and yet for me I think I'm used to I
think I'm I'm good at rip on people if
that's what we're doing I think I really
knew what we were doing
yeah I think it's I think I thought
rollerskates to a [ __ ] sword that's
funny
yeah that's good that's a good no I
think um because in previous
conversations I had with them it
more of a communication about kind of
real stuff that was going on in my
career right questions I had you know
and I come it was kind of looking up to
him I think also in some way for me as a
role model mm-hmm you know and when you
get when you get a certain response from
someone you have expectations on in your
own mind they for me when I get a
response to them that they don't they
don't realize that I see them that way
or it doesn't matter to them or whatever
and that's fine it's its own world I
built up in my head for some reason that
hits harder a little bit you know or it
like it's just a weird or dent but for
me also it's just like I'm not even a
[ __ ] interviewer dog you know I'm
saying like I don't know what I'm doing
are you doing our best but I was just
happy to sit down with him yeah as [ __ ]
and I think maybe we sat down maybe on
the wrong day maybe we started you know
I don't know but stuff we were talking
about off the podcast when I brought it
up on the podcast it was like we've
never spoken off the podcast and that
seemed very weird to me I had this same
reaction to him but like you made this
joke about do you have a do you have a
gun in your helicopter but he just I
don't know why he took that so the wrong
way oh yeah I think that's just a funny
I mean I mean if there's a funny premise
yeah I think at that point I I had also
at some point I'd kind of checked out I
think yeah you know I think I was kind
of but you you said to me that you don't
want to do guess anymore I'm doing no
I'm doing less guest:is I had the same
reaction to I was canceling episodes
after that oh no I was I needed to
cancel this is way before that I was
trying to can't pay her down we were
just trying to lie just too much stress
what do you mean what's stress about
what this year I just hit a level it was
just too much stress for me you know
just doing like you get in you know like
I started podcasting it was just me
talking to myself
mm-hmm which is what's always going on
in my head anyway and then and then you
get like oh and then you have a guest on
you try that and you're like oh it was
kind of cool and then you try it again
in a couple times it's really fun and
then you're like okay well do I
interview you know you see what other
people do you see what other podcast was
doing or interviewing all types of
people mm-hmm and so then I started
doing that and like just kind of finding
my way what fits and what doesn't forum
Brendan and I started that king in the
sting podcast
and that's just goofing around but it
also took a lot of took a lot of it took
time it took effort and so um it just
all became a lot and then with the tour
dates it literally too much it was about
two months man where I don't even know
like my my my thought my my piece I was
always a couple seconds off of peace of
mind it was just I was never able to
yeah yeah and just to feel okay or know
what was going on it was like I was
speeding but I didn't even know how to
work the vehicle or something and I was
still going real fast so that to me it
was just like I need to tell back what
am I don't want to be a comedian or are
we doing podcasting you have a lot of
podcasts going on here you have three
different sets in this studio well we
will yeah when we move King in the sting
in here yeah but this is only once in a
while now so this is kind of nice you
know now it's like okay I get to look
forward to a conversation as opposed to
being like okay you know getting right
here and being like all right I have to
do this conversation I know exactly what
you mean I was I was in the same place
where I was taking just trying to get
more interviews but you end up sitting
across people that you frankly don't
care about yeah that we're not
interested in or you don't have
chemistry
yeah wolf of wallstreet that happened
with me that guy I thought was just kind
of I don't know I didn't I don't know
just andand then I felt I couldn't
interview the way I wanted to is just
like I just didn't have enough of a plan
of why I was even talking to this guy I
know exactly what you mean yeah yeah
dude so the last time I saw you I'm
trying to think if that was right before
you kind of took a break that was one of
my finest interviews man was going in
there really well sometimes I like being
a guest better man I know exactly what
you mean man it's a lot of pressure
being the host you have to make sure the
shows running it's I find it one of the
hardest things as the host to be is like
to actually listen to what they're
saying but also being prepared where the
conversation goes next so there's not
dead air right and it's because I really
want to listen but sometimes I'll be
listening I'll be like huh and then you
don't know where you're going next yeah
see that's my worst moment has
host ah yeah yeah so ya know where you
can I guess it's great cuz it's all like
if this show sucks it's your fault I
feel like yeah yeah that's the thing I
think some of the hosting maybe or just
being like the person the inviter mm-hmm
you know it's almost like being a woman
during the sex profits I can't come over
here let's see what you got and if you
if you suck it's your fault right I love
that analogy yeah here we got a question
right here from a guy who might be Jack
London's son gay and gay and what up -
yo what up Ethan this is uh Chester pink
coming in from Detroit Michigan it's
cold out here man I just wanted to call
and ask Ethan when you got into YouTube
in what was like your goal like did you
have all this crazy success you know in
your head or were you just making funny
videos and and you know it just happened
organically I'm curious because I think
a lot of people get into what you do now
you know they see you and they say oh
man oh I want that
so they get into it maybe for different
reasons then they should or than you did
when you got it started so I'm just
curious so to hear the podcast anger
yang bra is cold he does look old man
Detroit but he looks like one of these
guys who's able to also like if you
bundle up too much you can't meet any
women you know that's the thing about
being a guy in the cold if you bundle
too much you're never gonna meet any
woman nothing like oh I'm gonna [ __ ]
this cotton ball going right they got to
see what's going on yeah you don't show
a little right whereas a guy will almost
unwrap anything to see if they could
[ __ ] it you know do you think that guy
should be able to like you know how I
mean women can walk around with their
cleavage out mm-hmm do you think the guy
should be able to show their dick off
like tight pants and maybe even maybe
like a maybe less the middle a window to
the balls or some [ __ ] Oh like a little
plastic window that you can see some
window to the balls and it was there
that old song right I feel like I just
want to see our dicks on the street
that's [ __ ] babe no nobody wants to
see my dick well
think if somebody if you could show that
the nuts in a way where you could see
the cleavage of them hmm not cleavage
that's what I mean oh now that's talking
but I don't the problem is your dick is
in front of your nuts you you willyou
you wrap it up you tape it up or some
[ __ ] yeah but now yeah that's gonna take
an extra six but it's a it's like the
peacock feathers it's the whole beauty
use thing like these girls spend a lot
of time getting ready the morning why
shouldn't we let's tape our dicks up and
get some [ __ ] nut cleavage out there
I'm telling you look I'm telling you man
forget about the winter clothes we gotta
get our nuts out there do you think you
have stylish dick or not I think my dick
used to be stylish but as I got older
and fatter my dick is get is turning
into like [ __ ] California raisin dude
is that true now what happens to your
dick is you get put on more weight I've
always kind of weighed the same well
your erection quality gets worse really
I think just because you know you're fat
you're out of shape you could you better
get that good blood flow oh my I mean it
works you know it's fine it works
ela laughs at me when I say that so she
has some confidence in my penis at least
but which is nice you know you want
someone to believe in your dick can she
uh does she um yeah I mean she must
enjoy your dick that's the thing about a
woman they have to enjoy that's the
thing about meeting a man is really a
two-part thing you have to meet you and
like you and then they also you have
this second buddy that they have to meet
mmm that they kind of have to like
enough no no I mean yeah it's like oh
you also gotta like my friend little rap
you know it's like yeah
why don't people like him some people
hate him hopefully you're one of the
ones that like him it's such a crazy day
she like she's yeah that's a that's a
really good point you know I feel like
vaginas not like that like it's all like
it's all good
yeah it's all pretty good I mean you put
it in and at a certain point like you
don't even have to really like see it
you know mmm just happens but but but
but to answer your question you know did
I have a question yeah about my penis
what happens when you get fat and old
well not old you're not all not 34 not
old
you're not old I'm 39 Oh how's your dick
working my dick has never worked that
great really yeah my dick worked really
good I was about 17 he's that I had a
real large penis since I was a very
young so the same size penis so it's got
small and it's smaller as you age no
it's gotten probably the same I think
it's looked different maybe you said
since you were since you were so what
age you had a big penis really young so
that's what I'm saying as you aged you
got bigger your penis stays the same
size dude I remember there were times
where I could rep both of my arms around
almost like that's how young like a
rapid or Ram my penis and pull it close
into my body like I remember yeah just
like almost like high like at one point
almost being able to not hide behind it
but I remember definitely being like
well that sounds pretty incredible so
what is the conflicts with it just that
it never grew it stayed that way and I
grew that's what I said it is yeah
okay so is its so are you happy with the
size of it and the thin though the you
know what I mean I think this is a
little bit more of like kind of a wider
penis it's more of like somebody trying
to park off sure it's more like a church
van type of a deal you know it's a joke
they say no it's not a chode is very
short I think chode is like a [ __ ] I kind
of bothering you you know I don't feel
like it's had I I don't think they're I
mean the way you're describing your
penis I think is uh sounds like
something beep something to be proud of
yeah maybe it is man I think yeah maybe
I have a negative idea of it what about
your penis man like I when I was younger
I was very proud of it I was like I'm
right want this thing to work I'm very
proud of this this is a beaut I like
this you ever shown it to women we were
shown oh oh well I didn't I didn't get
the opportunity you know really not that
much opportunity but I did I had nice
comments you know I never had a problem
it's good mm-hmm but you know my pubes
get longer like my dick all the sudden
when like I'm not hard my dick is like
you know it's like lost and it's like an
earthworm in a jungle of [ __ ] oh yeah
I know in a humid jungle dude hey I got
a mow the lawn and I'm getting fat I
came to see my penis these days boy Wow
does it really get wild when you get
starts put on some weight yeah oh wow
you can't
and you know I think is it like you're
looking for something sound like that so
I had anxiety problems in college I had
trouble getting it up to at certain
points oh now that was a nightmare dude
if there was a thunderstorm in the area
I couldn't get an erection I couldn't
get an erection you're broken glass I
had so much an essential anxiety man ton
of that I don't totally relate to that
it went away when I was in like
monogamous relationships that's when I
was able to perform at full mast you
know oh wow but but in other there was
times when I just I wanted to it was
such a shame you know cuz yeah you want
a polar would have been the perfect time
for that thing to work you know what I
mean dude I remember there was a girl I
met at Tulane University years ago and
we've been out met a met at a bar or
something I think I known her but
finally we met out and we went back to
her place or my place um I probably
didn't have a place but we went
somewhere to do sex and I remember just
couldn't get an erection
you know and I'm like and she and she's
ready to go
did I hide both my arms up everything
else in the everything was out
everything is erect bro well that makes
your penis look even sadder oh you're
like and I would wear tight socks even
keep blood flow into the more part you
really 100% does that work I felt like
it did thing but I don't know if it
really did but I would wear like those
compression socks you know like senior
citizens wear oh that's sick dude it was
so sad I level of it long [ __ ] on
[ __ ] you yeah one of the club I
wonder [ __ ] rolling into some comm
saw is that something to listen to Nelly
bro that's awesome though I wonder if
that's thing is that something guys do
bro hears it was that your idea or was
that shared with you no no that was mine
that was your original idea yeah I mean
it just me you're uh you're a
Renaissance man dude that's incredible I
don't know about that I mean that's all
I would I am I wish I thought of that
you ever do anything like that no I
can't say they have no but Nick's also
made some Nick's done a lot though Nick
put this whole studio together yeah you
must have a really nice day yeah I
thought you're gonna go into some more
of my poor choices oh yeah thanks saying
I was gonna but I'm trying to change the
way I think yeah so I'm trying to think
about you got a Gnostic for sure
but anyway yeah man and I met it so
anyway couldn't bro and here was the
excuse I remember that I use dude I had
to go meet somebody to go swimming but I
was like five oh you got out of there
yeah I was like I gotta meet somebody to
swim at 5:30 I remember people swim at
5:30 that's what I thought I'd seem to
be early morning everything yeah and
she's like really I was like yeah we got
a group I'm sad for that past year years
later yeah
meet up with her again same [ __ ]
thing because it's it's so still
direction mine connection is too strong
you because you remember that and you're
like all right I'm over that that's how
old me but the mind gets the best to you
yeah yeah yeah and that's what it was
dude I mean I'm so in my head I mean
it's so hard for me to leave my head to
live in a comfortable place in the world
that's why I'm constantly seeing all my
faults constantly seeing all my problems
constantly seeing you know all my you
know and people were like you got to
quit me as hard self I wish I could I
want to the bigger thing for me is I
just have to get out of my head and
because my head is just faulty you know
it doesn't work well great I'll tell you
what I know exactly what you mean I mean
I feel the same way but you know you
have this lens that you see the whole
world through them and when you when you
different people I've been through
different [ __ ] you know and it all Gunks
up your lens and you know you don't see
the world as it is but as you are right
yeah so so when your lens is all gunked
up and you've been through all this [ __ ]
and you know it's it's hard to see to
not see things all messy like that yeah
but do you go to therapy yeah I go to
therapy and I do 12-step you know a
recovery program so I go to 12-step and
that kind of stuff what are you
recovering from um I go to 12-step for
drugs and alcohol so what were you
addicted to you know I think honestly
when I really think back on it I was
addicted to the way that I think my
alcoholism is really now call ism is
yeah I have alcoholism mm-hmm so you
know I never drank much I would do some
cocaine sometime I really enjoyed it but
I mean my favorite drink was cocaine
really and
not alcohol but I would [ __ ] I'll
take a glass on it oh yeah
don't even [ __ ] put ice in it I don't
care man oh you know cocaine was just
really enjoyable it probably one of the
best powders that thing I don't like it
is that interesting really I've tried it
and I hated it made you real what did it
make you just you just like I drank a
bunch of coffee I didn't feel euphoric I
didn't feel confident I felt just like
on edge yeah I couldn't sleep it wasn't
I didn't feel good at all and I and I
would sit with people and they'd be like
talk people get so intense and like
chatty but I was I was very aware of the
that that wasn't like a real moment
between people it was just like you get
all [ __ ] crazy word burger yeah
people are [ __ ] calm but you're like
this conversation is all [ __ ] yeah
it doesn't make it's nothing and you
might sell your car who gives a [ __ ] to
even talk about for 40 minutes yeah
exactly
that's right that's so that's what I
think of when I when I think of cocaine
but I think I'm lucky in that my body it
rebels against drug use I always have
the worst experiences with all drugs but
you cocaine was good for you
no it wasn't actually actually I mean
Pierce is very much like you described
it hmm so what did you like about it I
think I liked that it gave me an excuse
to feel that way without like it wasn't
my fault anymore in a way because I
would feel like edgy I would feel like
you know just kind of overwhelmed or
something it's like oh well now it's at
least it's this this substances fault
not yours hmm
maybe I don't know interesting but in
the end I just realize it was for my
thinking you know my thinking I need to
have a program to help me relieve the
way that I think and the way I feel
about myself because those are really
the drugs that I'm addicted to I'm
addicted
I think feeling poorly about myself
right and I'm addicted to like this just
a negative system that started in my
head I think when I was young that right
you know just a bad software kana you
know I know exactly what you mean man
bye and you I think what you're saying
is right because your brain releases
chemicals that makes you feel certain
ways and when you're used to releasing
this chemical that makes you anxious
or stressed or whatever bad feelings you
have where your mind is racing and
you're thinking all these negative
thoughts this is the kind of chemical
your body gets used to producing and
it's hard to put a stop to that yeah
when you're just sitting calmly in your
house and your body's not producing that
[ __ ] and so it's hard to kind of change
rewire your system but the
antidepressant changed my life really
yeah that's what helped me rewire my
[ __ ] how long have you been on them over
a year Wow
[ __ ] yeah welcome wait yeah take it -
dude 20 years money years oh I see do
suppositories forego to the bar I'd put
two [ __ ] uh zoloft in my ass tea when
I was like gonna chart when I used to
live in Charleston why up your ass I
don't know this is about the time and I
think that kind of [ __ ] was popular you
know was kind of I don't think that is I
don't think met in a bad experience oh
dude I'll tell you it is bruh I could
drink thirteen gin and tonics fight two
of those in my ass man I don't think
you're supposed to drink on
antidepressants you're not I think what
they say actually is that it makes it
worse I mean it was all for me it always
felt like it was a bit a little bit bad
but I do remember I could the first time
I got Zoloft man it made me feel like oh
wow man I'm a cool guy
really I can drink I can get up early
and go do some oh and activated oh good
yeah what did it do for you nothing I
swear to god it it didn't affect me at
all the only thing that changed is that
I became less irritable which was which
was really like destroying my life is
just I was so [ __ ] irritable all the
time now irritable did that display
itself as like anger did everything
frustration yeah anger I will get like
irrationally angry at my wife oh yeah
and I know in my mind is the worst part
is like dude there's why why is this
making you so upset
mmm there's no reason for you to be this
upset over this but clean I couldn't
control it it's it's a it's a prison
you're a prisoner to your emotions in
that regard
dude is so funny said I went to the gym
this morning right and I hired a trainer
recently to help me just give me a
little more motor
and when I got there I was not just not
in a good mood man this is it was 9:00
a.m. you know so not that early but and
I told him I said hey man I'm just in a
really bad mood I said there's nothing I
can do about it I said I don't I'm
trying not to be I don't want to be but
it's like having a shirt on mmm it's
like just I'm in this shirt I have to
have this shirt on today mm-hmm and I'm
gonna do my best in this shirt but
there's no I can't [ __ ] change this
it's crazy yeah it's like you're being
something and you know you're in it yeah
it's it's really you're a prisoner to
your emotions and it's so frustrating
because Fogg Lanuf likes it like I feel
like such [ __ ] there were talking
mothers but it's real it's you know the
realest [ __ ] so I'm it's everything it's
everything it defines your whole how you
experience everything and it's so
frustrating knowing that you inside of
you is this how you want to be how you
wish you were and you know that that
you've been there and you you want to
feel that normality and but you just
you're you're you're in prison you can't
ask it and so for me the antidepressants
helped it did help it's not it like a
you know I still have bad days but for
the most part I feel like you know I
don't know the therapy helped a lot too
III talked and kind of thought about
things that I never thought about before
good therapist yeah I think so did you
try a couple before you went I tried one
through my health insurance he was it
was the work it was awful do they sent
me to a guy who did puppetry work dude
I'm like who the [ __ ] is this dude was
his name Jeff Dunham huh out of in wild
if you talk to Pina is puppet for
therapy and then jalapeno comes out
you're like what is this like yeah $200
an hour you would think it should be
[ __ ] Jeff Yeah right
did my therapist was 450 an hour no way
I was like man I'm like he's good but he
doesn't like give me a reach-around or
anything for fifty an hour dude he
should be cooking food for you shouldn't
be making that hate to interrupt you but
I am gonna because here we are look at
this look at me
it's me do you care by your eyes bro
well you should how was she gonna know
if you do or if you don't if you can't
even see yourself with my lifestyle and
the Sun here in California a lot of
times I don't know what's going on I'm
almost blind so I need sunglasses that
can really hold me down
Beck's B e^x sunglasses are badass
polarized sunglasses you can go to the
North Pole South Pole hell if you can
find the East Pole you can wear these
there they are tough and clear as hell
you can get shot out of a damn shuttle
right into a damn wall and you're gonna
be a-ok what I love about my Beck's
glasses is anything can happen if you're
drunk if you're not drunk if you're a
cop pulls you over put them on what's
going on is it bright outside anything
can happen you want to buy a van you
want to get a you want to get attacked
by somebody do it in style don't look
like some cheap person who's getting
attacked
Beck's sunglasses they are light they
are rugged they are polarized made with
luxury materials by the finest
craftsmanship in the world Beck
sunglasses perform under the harshest
conditions buy your sunglasses from
Beck's sunglasses calm that's B e^x
sunglasses dot-com and use code Theo for
20% off your entire order bra that's
right go to Beck's sunglasses calm and
use code Theo these glasses I really
like them I can I can be stylish I can
be romantic in it you could look at
somebody and you could suddenly hug them
if you want and that's what happens with
these amazing spectacles look I know
that everybody listening here comes from
all walks of life and some non walk
people in wheelchairs and everything and
there are these
there are two things that bring people
closer together comedy and the ability
to get insane goods at a very cheap
and I've got that second option covered
right now by italic italic has tons of
stuff from both men and women from
luxury handbags wallets cashmere
sweaters bedding bath towels cookware
even water bottles from the best
manufacturers in each category I don't
know if you've ever made an effort to
dress like that little donkey man chris
d'elia but it isn't cheap these designer
shoes and bags can cost thousands of
dollars with italic they sell products
manufactured by the same companies at a
much much lower price so if it's about
the feel it's about the actual product
and not about the name then this is what
you want get sheets from the same
manufacturer as st. Regis and Four
Seasons a backpack from the same
manufacturer as to me a purse from the
same manufacturer as Prada and so on so
on spruce up your closet your gift
selection and the planet with italic
that's right the planet italic plants
one tree with every order so you can
feel smart about saving money and good
about helping the environment that's not
all italic are offering this past
weekend listeners a special deal on
their insane prices use the code Theo th
EO at checkout for a twenty dollar
credit that can go towards any order
over $100
that's ITA l IC dot com italic dot-com
offer code Theo th EO for $20 off any
order over $100 you want quality this is
your time we got a question right here
from a beautiful young Filipino oh we
never answered the first one huh
yeah but he knows we care i I can answer
it now can we hop back to it because
this one's kind of related what I
couldn't I remember the question was uh
what did you plan when you started
youtube did you want to get famous did
you sell it rich
no what I plan I'll tell you I remember
the exact moment I I knew I wanted to
call me and
to be an entertainer I never thought
that I could ever be on screen because
it's like when you're don't have
connections and I didn't ever really
wanted to be a stand-up comedian
that I knew that wasn't my path just
because I don't know because of three
you were brave in some comedic way too
you knew that about yourself because you
did like Veit you know I was watching
vapenation the other day yeah that and
you did but you know you were that's
kind of a brave strange thing yeah I
mean those videos were really hard to
make it's uh it's it's intense going on
the street and doing that but in the
very beginning I thought I'd be a writer
or something cuz but but at any rate I
remember I was watching Jimmy Kimmel of
all people and he says you know these
days with YouTube if you're funny and
you're and you work hard enough and
you're talented you know back in the day
you had to know somebody had to be
connected but these days if you're funny
and you just put yourself out there on
YouTube eventually something's gonna
happen for you
mmm there's something that the essence
of that and so I was like you know
that's that's true like I'm sitting
around trying to find like someone to
give me an opportunity or something you
know I was I was working a day job
I was I was full-time doing some
marketing [ __ ] so so I started on on
the weekends just just making a goofy
YouTube videos just not with any
expectation at all just to get my chops
to find my voice to figure out what I
liked and who I was comedic ly mm-hmm
and I did that for like two years you
know we collected a small following of
people which I was so I mean I was so
blessed
there was like in the beginning days
there was like I had a very loyal small
group of people that found me somehow oh
yeah I was like the Book of Eli back
then everything that movie know kind of
similar with someone Will Smith finds
his dog or whatever I am Legend he was
like I am Legend I did see that but I
don't get early on to buy mean because
there's only 1 / T were the only person
there there's like people wandering
around is trying to find their group a
few people I see but but while I was
trying to think of take another
antidepressant yeah
yeah I put them up you still put them up
your butt huh no no that was a college
that's good should take him by the mouth
of thing I take him out of mouth yeah
man
but don't you get left with a bunch of
like powder in your ass where does it
just soak it all up no dude this is back
when I had a pretty [ __ ] design or I
[ __ ] were you young your [ __ ] a
[ __ ] it's just a sweet tight little
question bits of Hocking yeah it's like
it's just like a new one day of yeah
it's the Fountain of Youth and now your
[ __ ] seen some mileage no it's just
you know it's more of a you know it's
just had it's probably feels like it
seems like it's just had no mileage is
the turn you know the city yet the
Ottoman for the city's always taking
great care of it yeah that's fair you
ever take a [ __ ] like a big ass [ __ ] it
feels so good coming out it's a very
pleasant experience and you look and
it's like big ass [ __ ] like and you're
like damn I kind of get why dudes like
ain't [ __ ] in the ass nope but because
it's like damn like if it can feel that
like a [ __ ] that big just came out of my
ass and I didn't even mind it one bit
you know what I mean I won't take really
big shits I'll wait till they feel a
little bit smaller and then I take well
if you oh but I don't have control over
that
I don't wait it just happens when it
happens well you can wait I mean it's in
your body good no for me it's like Now
or Never
no it's like now it's not never when I
need a [ __ ] I need a [ __ ] there's no
holding back
damn you're like the [ __ ] this is
like the fastest I got that yeah Oh
Jewish bowels yeah I have Jewish bowel
syndrome oh dude yeah my Jewish buddies
you give him half a teaspoon of [ __ ]
yeah
sour cream oh yeah see I'm for a while
yeah that's right that's true yeah we
call that Jewish bowel syndrome
there it is now I just made that up but
it should be a thing bro it's so crazy
but you know it's hardest most capable
humans do but you know what half of a
[ __ ] cracker that doesn't agree with
Eden even need the Holocaust you
could've just distributed sour cream to
the population that's the final solution
do you know why cuz we're all inbred oh
yeah yeah we're just inbred as [ __ ] so I
guess that does something but we all
have mental district Tourette's syndrome
you know I'm
can mass we had a question that came in
about that let's get right to that we
didn't have a question about the
Tourette's but we never mind we had a
gas can I work for different particle we
had a guest named oh yeah we had a guest
that came in named knit uh mark mark
mark Elliott he would give TED talks cuz
he cured his Tourette's through the name
in the system of a damn what was in that
sex cult that would dad Keith Ranieri I
got a little weird you know Vick sent
over that in Vicks yeah yeah he was in
that he was like kind of like in one of
like the he was like a sidepiece kind of
well I'm not surprised because that's
definitely not possible there's a lot of
different things that are like
Tourette's
but you turrets as a neurological well
let's see this is what he's got oh wait
is this the ugly guy is this the guy you
interviewed yeah oh I can't diagnose him
if that's what you're asking you can try
that it's YouTube man school there was
15 kids in the class like there's so
many different tic disorders there's a a
new neurological disease I just heard
about on the news that kind of manifests
its like self like Tourette's I mean I
couldn't possibly diagnose the guy and
for me it's a it's a here it's a
heretical condition my uncle has it my
it's passed down for my family we used
to see your uncle do you guys have a
different type of life because they're
like a sixth sense almost well his is
worse than mine so it's kind of it's
really easy to spot but is it when you
see him is there is there like here's
what I'm saying like if I had wings on
my back right and I saw somebody else
with wings on their back I would be like
oh you know is there camaraderie between
yeah like really what because I'll tell
you in my experience I breaks my heart
man it was a very personal experience
that I never met anyone else that had
Tourette's growing up I never knew
anyone else so for me it was very only
one yeah that I ever knew
and it's a very personal
experience in battle the way I felt it I
didn't I preferred not to talk about it
because I feel like even being aware of
it made it worse
so like when my parents try to talk to
me about it I would just tell them you
know I'll get upset I would say just
don't bring it up to me because I don't
want to I felt like the less I was aware
of it
I less it bothered me if he didn't make
it a big thing these days about it
doesn't bother me so much but as a kid
it's a lot to work out in your head and
it was worse when I was a kid too so I
think I was very lucky that was very I
was very fortunate to have friends who
were very cool and understanding and not
judgmental about it because I I can see
that that could that could really oh
yeah [ __ ] you up growing up but I mean I
was so fortunate to have friends that
were very we're very generous with their
compassion mm-hmm yeah that's huge cuz
imagine that you have yeah you have that
and people are just giving you a hard
time yeah it'll look weird as [ __ ] it's
hard to control it and what kind you
have what kind of because sometimes you
get we had a guy that was always that
kind of playing freeze tag with himself
it seemed like we had a guy we had a
blind guy that's not tourettes we had a
guy what else did we have dude we had a
gun we had a dude who was he would
always ride this bicycle that had a baby
seat member the baby seat he would sit
behind your mom on the seat and those
used to be dope now these kids riding
like a [ __ ] big covered wagon or
something here in [ __ ] England or
something you know but we used to ride
over just a seat with like a shitty
[ __ ] seat belt mhm and you were just
sitting there like it bounced behind mom
we had to do it in our town that was
like he had some type of something and
he would just drive one of those all the
time but no baby in the back and people
always thought that something had
happened he'd lost his family or
something but what was yours like I just
had so when I was a kid it was it's a
weird thing I feel like what what
Tourette's you can pass around your tics
so like for example I have where I open
my eyes real wide mhm and that you use
you don't want to draw attention to
yourself right that's what you avoid
okay I hide it inside of yourself like I
have one where I roll my
so I would I would like cover my eyes so
people didn't notice or I don't wear
shake my head that one that one really
bothered me it gave me headaches all the
time so what you could what I found you
can do is if you resist the urge hmm
your body will manifest new tics in
different ways so I would like fight off
this urge to shake my head cuz it drew
attention to myself and I didn't like
that and now instead I wiggle my toes oh
wow you can't see that you don't know
I'm wiggling my tight [ __ ] like that so
you can redirect I found personally that
I can redirect the tick energy so with
things surgery that's trying to escape
you the best way I can describe it is
like you it's it's not like I don't have
control over it I cannot do it but it's
like having an itch it's like having it
yes so it's like you know it's it so
it's awful it's a horrible feeling not
scratching an itch drives you crazy
that's even what Mark even said I
remember him saying something like that
Mark Elliott said it was like having an
itch and some you have to scratch it and
you have to do something to scratch it
and sometimes you don't ya just that's
the best way I can describe it I don't
know what he's got as far as I'm aware
that you know Tourette's is not it's not
a curable yeah he thanked the NICS 'i'm
cult whatever their their organization
their process was for getting rid of
before look into that he did more vocal
he had more vocal tics did you ever have
vocal so teressa's
is characterized by a vocal tics okay so
mine was clearing my throat like I do
that I still do that no it's cool I
think oh I thought I'd muted it that's
the difference between like tech
syndrome and and like an Tourette's
syndrome Tourette's is what is
characterized by vocal tics so was there
any fun ones you would get sometimes no
there's no there's no fun one they're
all annoying they're all annoying it's
just a matter of like being able to
they're actually they're not all
annoying so it doesn't necessarily
bother me that I have to wiggle my toes
but I have like you know I have like a
sleep paralysis where you wake up or you
you're in a semi-conscious state you
know what sleep rouse oh yeah I love it
that's sarcastic no I love sleep rouses
when you get that thing where you're
like really off you know every waking
every time I go to sleep I pray for that
dude I love that [ __ ] really
yes I'll do all month can you expand on
that yeah like so now yeah like you wake
up and but you're not really awake and
you can't move but you're like alive you
know I mean that sounds awful the way
you describe really yeah cuz boring to
me so I'm sleepy so far more terrifying
it's like I'm just gonna lay here for
seven hours you know I like sleeping
dude yeah look I've thought it ruled for
sometime and then recently the probably
Lord yeah pass away it is a waste of
time technically speaking yeah I just
feel like in the future things like can
you believe that when our
great-grandparents were tired they went
late somewhere for eight hours we could
eliminate that think of how psychotic it
seems really yeah to think that man oh
you are you think you forgo well she
went and laid down a specific close your
eyes for eight hours yeah that sounds
like [ __ ] autism bro yeah this lady
has a question right here video hey
Ethan have you gotten a hit of that
nurse and ela too if not have you
thought about it mmm no like oh wow
Gang Gang I like how excited she was by
that she got a lowered her voice and
changed her mannerisms she looks nice
when she has two tits till you see that
have you had a Maya I certainly thought
about it you tried either breast milk
the thing is that ela wasn't I probably
would have but ela wasn't she was having
trouble lactating okay so we've we
feeding him he was actually like
starving to death during the first two
weeks and it was awful we didn't know
why he wasn't getting enough food
because eel is oh she's nursing he's not
getting up yeah he or she wasn't really
producing and so I would have told I
would have totally sucked the milk out
of her titties I mean I've tried many
times before really even before she was
pregnant
that's [ __ ] pretty cool no I'll retry
it look dude everybody is yeah
everybody's had a sip of different
things that come
their body you know everybody's you know
I'm no [ __ ] you know even immoral
Lagasse does like that oh yeah little
bamm-bamm yeah a little BAM yeah I would
have tried it you know I've heard good
things
how has I know last time you and I were
talking on your podcast man which was
really fun dude I'm so appreciate it
that you guys have me on I've gotten
such a nice response over the years from
I want you to hear bangle that let's
come back okay good soon we were talking
I wanna go we're in the same building we
could go up there right now nope we're
here right now but how about this I'll
come back after I would say probably
after the first of the year I'll come
back love it yeah let's get that we
close and thank you and uh but yeah we
were talking about parenting and
fatherhood and stuff like that has your
relationship with your dad changed since
you had to have had a child has it been
well have you had any moments to reflect
like I just don't think it works that
way you can you can change yourself
mhm you can inform yourself and and you
know hopefully improve your relationship
with your own son but I don't I just
don't think that things change like that
unfortunately it's not like it's not
like I don't know no now no not really
not with my dad yeah I mean I have a
fine relationship with my dad you know
we all yea I'm not throwing him under
the bus for me no I I do all the time he
gets angry at me because he listens oh
yeah my mom started listening yeah which
is sweet in a way but it's like isn't it
sweeter know what it's like you got it
just buckle up if you're gonna listen
cuz I I'm just gonna talk about
everything yeah you're gonna hear things
you don't want to hear from from you
know how I wipe my ass yeah you know I
recently started using a bidet and I had
a lot of success with that wow really -
sucking on you know he'll try suck milk
out of my wife's titties and even saying
you know hey I don't think you did that
good job as a father yeah so they got to
be prepared for all that but I don't
think it's prepared I don't think it's
improved my relationship with my dad at
all I think mostly it's just um I
learned a lot about my relationship with
my dad through therapy hmm and that kind
of stuff was was very good I think with
preparing me to be a father
but are you digging it yeah of course
yeah of course you know he's five months
old right but it's it's just there's a
lot of stuff there's a lot of great
stuff and there's a lot of people
prepare you for
I think people oversell it and in this
way they say first of all people go when
my child was born is the best day of my
life that day sucks that's like [ __ ]
such an awful day
you don't sleep your wife is going under
this incredible dangerous procedure
she's an incredible pain you then then
you have this crying little Goblin that
you you have no like in my I mean I'm a
first-time father so you don't know what
you're doing yet this baby is it can't
even lift it's [ __ ] Mecca for oh he's
that kind of a I like that on our
basketball team when I was young like
you don't hold his neck up and he breaks
his [ __ ] head falls in Florida you're
like oh [ __ ] and then yeah I think it's
so straight left enough to do a layup in
the middle of a game yeah that doesn't
sound like a very good that sounds like
a dysfunctional basketball - yeah this
is bad but no so that day is horrible
that day get it's such an awful day it's
so you know and it is beautiful when the
baby comes out right but at the same
time there's a ton of people there it's
kind of confusing because you don't know
what to do you know my heel is on the
heel is on the table she's getting sewn
up cuz her [ __ ] tore into my job you
know that happens pretty commonly and he
was a big baby and his shoulders just
[ __ ] bad bro and by the way shoulders
in there well they're there they're real
flexible I mean and the crazy [ __ ] did I
saw everything by the way you think that
like Oh dad's just gonna sit outside I
was [ __ ] holding her leg I saw I I
didn't have a choice they threw me in
the [ __ ] John Wayne Gacy bro I didn't
have a choice at all that's what they
instructed me they said dad come grab
her leg I'm saying all right let's get
it let's do it you know right here I'm
here to support my wife but it was crazy
scene I saw everything his head looked
like a meatball coming out of her
because it was all discolored and lumpy
and little hairs it looked like a
meatball with pubes I swear to God broke
the no joke this story right here is
better than
entire last movie of Halloween you say
that last one no no my show really it
was he was scary
really it was almost like a average
husband for Cutco knives dude it was a
[ __ ] worst horror movie I don't I
don't like horror movies I skip them all
well then watch that dude it's nothing
but it's kind of like a man like window
shopping for houses well yeah oh yeah I
mean this oh yeah I felt safe but it was
intense
her you know her [ __ ] was and then like
dude the gnarliest thing it's like so
the uterus are not the uterus that that
stays in there the the placenta the baby
comes sell that you sell that's a Joe
Rogan bro they want you to eat that [ __ ]
I'm like [ __ ] that what are you insane
my campbell oh there's one of these
[ __ ] [ __ ] from Montana Boulevard
or something you know probably put it in
a smoothie for people kept trying to get
me to eat it I'm like I'm first of all
Wow no I don't be that I'm telling I'm
taking down names and people who told me
to eat it so I could not talk to them
but you should have seen it they cuz the
bill you cut the umbilical cord and then
you got it and then you pull the [ __ ]
placenta out by the umbilical cord since
she hasn't she was like a second birth
the baby's out getting checked out by
the doctors and then meanwhile the the
nurse is pulling this placenta out and
it looks like a liver it's just huge
organ bro and it's all you see it's all
bloody and there's all these veins and
[ __ ] end up dude and they pull it out of
that crazy to see do you ever look at
your wife the same I mean him yeah what
yeah you know she's better than she's
awesome nothing she's not a great person
but I'm just saying dude if somebody
know I didn't it ice when you 'only
think that it didn't it didn't know I
mean it was it was [ __ ] crazy but I
saw more than she did right she didn't
see any of that right
and then the nurses are going on and on
about like oh it's such a it's such a
beautiful placenta it looked like a
[ __ ] raw liver bro got pulled out of
her vagina that sounds like an teef I do
that sounds fun and like and then
there's this newborn baby I've never
dealt with and the doctors are all
checking him out and [ __ ] and I mean
he's scary it's scary and then they put
you in the hole and the hot in the
recovery room and you got to keep this
baby alive for two days and then they
send your ass home and you got to keep
the baby alive there was it scary to
leave the hospital that would seem scary
to me like I was I wanted to get out of
the hospital was a just awful I hate it
being there I wanted to get out of there
when we got home the first two months
was just agony because well I think we
had a specifically a hard time because
he wasn't latching on he was a feeding
he was latching on but he wasn't feeding
oh and you know breast feeding is very
painful for the female - is it really
yeah they say that breastfeeding is is
oftentimes even even worse than the
pregnancy that's something that I could
imagine I didn't think about that just
sucking hard and munching munching on
the titty you know what I mean
not just sucking munching yeah very
animalistic yeah and he was just crying
I mean it was just crying crying and
crying and crying we're like I don't
think he wants to cry this one's you
know he was he wasn't sleep they're
supposed to sleep like 18 hours a day he
was sleeping like maybe five at Mawson
he was just crying crying crying and
there's a cigarette smoker it's almost
sounds like us someone to the key they
don't sleep that much cigarette smokers
people don't think about that mmm but
anyway I interrupted you um so oh is
that the elevator oh you guys have
elevator noise we didn't think about
that
mmm can they hear it nope that's good
it's not a big deal I think it's kind of
sexy yeah yeah I saw you guys have a
sign please don't use the elevator I
thought that was all you a nickel of
that sign I think right now I think it's
not at the moment cuz there's so much
therapy upstairs I started to feel bad
about yeah oh yeah so yeah I yeah one
day we did area lady in a wheelchair
really you should probably just let her
take that elevator
sound quality man that's like did did
the baby seem like oh now does it seem
human at first or does it seem like an
animal or like a Pettifer and not in any
way you don't love the child no so
really it's a little gremlin bro yeah
it's a little it's a little troll do you
love it as much in the beginning as you
much you're in know of it now if I know
and that's another thing they don't tell
you is that when this bait it's a
stranger you never met this baby you
don't know each other
and so um so no that's the kid that's
the truth your your love grows for for
the child right and it's not a you you
don't have an immediate connection and
that's something that worried me as well
that was like you know I'm not really
connecting with this baby at first and I
mean that's different now
no no he's five months old and he's
smiling and he's laughing and it's the
whole thing he's much different but at
first especially for the two first two
months there's no there's almost no
recognition of you at all so so that's
another thing that that I think you
don't expect that maybe people aren't
honest about mmm because everybody I
think in retrospect like when they're 20
years old or whatever it's even five six
years old it's like you just think
you're all you see all the happy good
times and you look back on that with
with the not just rose-colored glasses
but but uh dark pink
what's more intense than Rose chiffon
maybe I'm Jevon baby fawn colored
glasses is that something it sounds good
yeah but you know were you it was tough
were you grew was there a moment where
you kind of started refeel grateful like
okay wow I am starting to love like yeah
there was a moment where I realized now
he's [ __ ] he's like five months in a
week and he's really been coming into
his own for the past month or two and
there's there's like this moment every
day when he first sees you and it's so
happy to see you and you know what I
real I had this weird realization that
you think that you know your parents are
meant to have unconditional love for you
but but what I realized as a parent is
that this child has unconditional love
for me right now and it was like it was
very sobering realization that he went
it's almost like I feel unworthy of that
love hmm
he's just so happy to see me every time
and happy to spend time with me that
it's it's it's freaky like it's what he
does for me and not the other way around
and you have I feel like I have and it's
not just with me either it's with
everybody like he's born so pure and
loving that as a parent you need to you
need to protect that oh that's
interesting you need to because the
truth is I think we're all born that way
and only through our life experiences do
we does that change yeah you know that
there's a debate that are we born good
or not and I think once you see a baby
there I mean it's obviously that we are
all born good Wow and it's just through
our life experiences that the dark arts
that any of that changes so you know you
have a responsibility and it's it's so
weird that when you realize like that
you're gonna be the one new effective
well it's such a profound relationship
the father-son relationship right mm-hmm
let's get this Filipino we got a
beautiful Filipino man mmm as a question
for hey Theo my name is Rizzo I'm from
North Carolina my questions mainly for
Ethan my question is when you're
battling darkness and depression and
dark thoughts yourself how do you go
about having a better brighter
perspective for your child when you're
dealing with negativity yourself how do
you aim for positivity with your child
in the nick of time that's what we call
him right now thanks Nate
well I feel like first of all it's more
like how do you deal with it yourself
you know it's like you have to get your
[ __ ] straight for yourself right before
you can't you can't if you're feeling
that way you can't help it bleeding
through
to your kid and he's gonna see that and
he's gonna learn for that he's gonna
take it did you start to realize yeah
you're like this weird filter everything
bro
he watches he learns he everything you
know he they take it in it changed them
day by day they that you know what I
mean they're a little DNA they're
building blocks are taking everything in
bro as a building a little human being
and for me you know one of the fallacies
that I had when I was depressed and
anxious and really in the pit of despair
you have this feeling in your head you
chase yourself in circles and circles
and circles the truth is you can't talk
yourself out of it you cannot change it
you need something to slice through it
day by day you just you try to convince
yourself you try to find different ways
that you can feel better but for me I
found that it's all just that's all part
of it dude that's not escaping it that's
the trappings of it right and for me
it's just you know therapy and medicine
was what helped me get out of it because
you can't you just can't talk yourself
out of it are there moments now I
remember having a moment where I felt
like one of the first times I felt good
about myself hmm did you have anything
like that happened after you got on and
in depressants like and I'm not saying
that any presses are the cure for these
things I'm just saying that that moment
for me happened when I will got into
12-step program that I remember having a
day one day one moment I was walking and
I was like what is going on I said oh
wow I feel I feel
yeah I have had more I certainly have
moments of clarity and it's almost
[ __ ] scary yeah that's the thing is
like before I used to have good days and
then just the the awareness oh yeah that
I had a good I'm having a good moment or
a good day made me ruined my day okay
for real yeah yeah for real like it
ruined it well I can relate to that yeah
so much it's unbelievable
but I think that that's but I do have
moments of clarity where I am like I
think back to how bad I was yeah and you
know I'm very thankful for that the you
know it's a little better yeah let's get
let's throw another question now I want
to talk what do you talk what are you
working on in therapy right now like
what do you I'm trying to think of I
don't go to therapy anymore you don't I
went for like three months for four
months and I feel like I got I made a
lot of progress and I thought about a
lot of stuff and I think there was just
a month well first of all was super
expensive and is super far from my house
it was kind of a pain in the ass and I
think it came to the point where I felt
like it was more of a pain in the ass
than therapeutic respect I had a moment
the other day of my therapist yesterday
actually I was in there and I didn't
like the fact that she kept someone
she'll just tell me facts and [ __ ] and I
don't I don't learn really that way I
learn more from feeling like from me I
really need to feel something too
especially in therapy I need to have
some feelings for it to really be of any
value to me mm-hmm
I don't care whenever they're talking
about like well maybe the reason of this
is that it's like I need to have the
feeling I need to realize it myself I
need to communicate it to myself almost
right with your help
right and I remember telling her I said
you know I don't like when you talk
mm-hmm and it was kind of interesting
because we started to get into this
space where it's like she's like that's
fine you can tell me that sort of thing
and this whole time I've had this thing
in my head where I'm just like I'm just
trying to be nice at the same time it's
also getting therapy hmm but sometimes
you can use your therapist to embody
things that you don't like like they're
doing something you know I didn't
realize that I didn't
I can say you know I don't like hearing
you talk right now you know yeah I had a
moment like that too it's like well why
and then I get to start to explain why
and then I get to start to realize
something that's bothering me and I'm
actually then dealing with it instead of
just like talking to my therapist like
right even you can fight you can even go
that's right that's why I therapy you
need to be like radically honest yes and
radically honest in a way that I didn't
even know was being radically honest
like yeah I was like you know what I
[ __ ] hate it when you start to tell
me like well maybe this is you know and
I know that [ __ ] mm-hmm I [ __ ] know
that mm-hmm I know what's going on I
just don't [ __ ] feel good mm-hmm but
it was finally like an opportunity when
I started to get there I was like oh
this is a new space for me to
communicate interesting because one of
my biggest problems really is
communication I don't communicate
clearly sometimes in the beginning and
then I start to live in these worlds
where I did communicate clearly mmm but
I never really did communicate are you
talking about with friends or in all
hours I think in all facets hmm
so then I start to build these weird
resentments and things you won't learn
in my head when I just didn't
communicate clearly from the beginning
mm-hmm but it's so hard for me to want
to communicate clearly I don't know then
then I start to realize okay that's
where I have like admission you don't
have the energy you don't have the well
took like extra communicate I think I I
think I just no one ever really taught
it to me so I think I could learn weird
ways to communicate mm-hmm even when I
probably why I ended up doing stand-up I
ended up needing to have this way to
communicate with people to just feel
like somebody hears me you know I don't
know I think a lot of it I'm still
learning about but it's just anyway I
just went on that tendon cuz I I just
realized that for myself in therapy that
I can also communicate with my
favoritest about how I feel about them
yeah because it's gonna help us as a
team learn about what's going on and I
can even tell them hey don't take this
personally I know that I'm I know you
know that I care about you I know that I
think you're a nice person but I'm gonna
communicate this way to play like that
I'm in good ones
imagine a therapist getting all like
defensive yeah I couldn't either but I
always thought no yeah we don't want to
be rude right and you know then you have
a weird thing we're like you like them
and they they they know you more than
they know what's going on through your
head more than your closest the people
closest you in your life
yeah and you you want them to think
highly of you yes because they know you
so well so weird them you know like a
therapist about your therapy we there
needs to be a book on how to go to
therapy I agree it's it's because
there's a teaching for the therapist
there's no teaching for the therapy for
them you know for the therapist you know
or whatever the guy comes in here's my
[ __ ] dude right here this guy was uh
Whitney the quarterback from a TV show
Sugar Hill Gang or somewheres the guy
with a guy at wheelchair market eight
not a guy who got in the wheelchair and
then went to the city championship
that's him with the nut with the black
guy that played Superman who played
Superman there was a black Superman
Friday Night Lights oh I thought it was
called Market Market a dude that's what
they always say what is this guy you
know I'm talking about Philip Allen or
something I got quarterback I read the
book one dude
sorry what's up my question is for Ethan
my wife and I are massive fans of
annually in the podcast and everything
in the whole channel happen for a long
time my question is as a husband and now
a new father what does it feel like
responsibility wise to put your family
out there for the internet and how has
that impacted you of recent now thanks
well in certain ways it sucks because we
get swatted and there's a lot of people
that wish us ill will and we moved
recently because we didn't feel safe at
our last house where people calling the
police and saying less here you people
calling police and saying there's bodies
everywhere there's bombs everywhere
there's hostages and the SWAT teams
would pull up to our house and
helicopters and they would come with
their guns drawn and I serious yes and I
felt very unsafe
I felt very unsafe about it and so we
moved to a new house and a gated
community which is nice I feel better
there but it sucks being a public figure
in that regard because there's always a
little bit of uncertainty because
there's just so many crazy [ __ ]
people up there and there's I don't know
there's people that dislike me on the
internet for one reason or the other and
I wish I could erase that you know I
didn't know if I would like you probably
when I met you man but I realized I
really did like you you know I wonder
what that is they'll wonder I mean and I
don't mean that any bad way I mean it
almost in a way to explore you know like
I guess I just thought we might be so
different you know but then I realized
that's true yeah and I was kind of like
oh we're really not very very different
I know I don't know why but I had a
feeling like I was I was friends with a
lot of your your contemporaries the
comedian's mm-hmm and I knew I wanted to
meet you but I don't know why like when
I saw you at the comedy club I really
wanted to yeah saw you guys meet you and
I'm glad I'm glad that you said hello
yeah that was cool yeah maybe I don't
know why I don't know what it was but
your set was amazing
finally dates I appreciate that man yeah
yeah it's been a fun uh that job's been
fun it's been good to me but what what
is it that you think you wouldn't like
about me no I don't know I think I think
I feel like I don't know I sometimes I
feel like certain people just judge
would just judge me for some reason you
know hmm
but then I realize that uh I don't know
let me think about I am judgmental I'm
kind of known for that well I think it's
also probably cuz i know cuz I'm
judgmental hmm and so then I always am
one dick to another right so I know that
so then my biggest fear is always that
other people gonna be you know it's
funny I I always think this to myself if
I met myself I think I would like myself
maybe maybe that's less true now but
back in the back when I was like really
uh in a dark place mm-hmm
I used to be
that if I was outside myself and my
[ __ ] hate myself yeah
sometimes I felt like that earlier this
year I hit a real bat I had a bad spot
this year for a couple months and it's
still a bit this whole years been really
tough for me but I hit a bad spot early
this year where I was [ __ ] just a
nightmare mm-hmm and I hated it it was
the same thing like you know sometimes
it just flares up and it's just like I
don't know I have some anger and it just
won't I just can't get yeah I almost
want to [ __ ] exorcism or something
you know mmm I wish it was that easy
crazy I wish I was [ __ ] possessed
yeah at least I could explain it you
know do you think about back in the old
days if you're like oh sorry
okay this just goes to me yeah caught a
bad demon on the stagecoach yeah man
they just take a little blood call it a
day
oh let's get a question right here in
this guy right here definitely kind of a
Gregory thing yep Robert well what's
happening guys this is Shane hey
Australia I am in Sidney Theo at the end
more show that you did that was great
this question is aimed more at Ethan
whoever who might recognize me from this
tattoo what is your own Thank You gang
gang populace oh he's got all the
slogans Shangri again bless ya gang
bless rah
that's our pile of I've seen that tattoo
so many times it's it's a Rick and Morty
Rick Sanchez doing vape Nations I just
met with no I didn't meet with that
studio today I met with a minister your
bento box I met with some of those guys
um but let's focus on this guy man thank
you for coming out to the show there and
my favorite vid well vapenation such I
think vacations everything on my face
that thing was like it was such a it was
like the vape God's blessed me because
mean he'll I just walked out with no
plan at all Wow I had an outfit and a
vape and a dream and the gods were
gracious because like I had all these
incredible interactions like he went to
the vape store and the guys were amazing
we went did we were walking down the
street and the news was live which is
some
that I had never seen that were great
that didn't really [ __ ] live and we're
beeping in the marry me yes he engaged
the answering is crazy and like I mean
everything was going on there we were in
Central Park and I was yelling at the
police and they interact with me
we went down to Central Park and a cop
let me sit in his [ __ ] car and vape I
mean it was all just the vape gods were
on my side you know everything was
beautiful about that video but another
one I'd say another favorite I don't
know that I did this video called a 90's
boy band where I was making fun of these
uh frosted tip deep tanned boy bands oh
yeah and we just went on a whole
adventure through New York City where I
got this fake tan and frosted my tips
and I was on the subway applying tan it
stinks so bad by the way that tan yeah
you can get something that has smells a
little not as bad but I was amazed by
how foul-smelling and in a petting zoo
you know if you wear too much bronzer it
won't let you in certain petting zoos -
why is that it just the animals have a
bad reaction - they stop you and do they
have like a Pantone they they check your
tan levels man I wouldn't have been
allowed in there for sure
yeah but that was fun that was a really
fun video yeah well but vapenation I
mean even for myself it's like it is
yeah it's beyond me it's funnier than
thank you babe nation what is it I had a
moment when you're talking about that
it's interesting how sometimes with
creativity if you just take that like
you said you had your girl or you you
know who's your partner in crime you had
a camera you had a little bit of an idea
and then you went and sometimes that's
so much better than although it's true
in the world it is and sometimes and
most of the times it's way worse and
that's the problem that's the problem I
ran into is because I kept trying to
rebuttal that lightning and it was
always okay but ultimately it's it's
just it's it's tricky because sometimes
it's way better but most of the time
it's worse so it gets fresh the process
gets frustrating and ultimately I think
you learned that you need to be more
structured and do more structure yeah
yeah
it's interesting cuz sometimes it's like
if something doesn't happen for the
first time if it's not exactly new which
is one of the reasons why I think I like
laughter is because it's such a you
didn't know it was coming
hmm and it's gonna be gone hmm and it's
just there's no denying that it you
can't hide the emotion right you can't
hide the emotion you kid there's no
denying that it occurred and that it was
a it's almost like the Big Bang Theory
of communication hmm
you know it's like you know the first
thing my son learned to do was laugh and
smile is another trip it's crazy it's
the first thing they learn to
communicate is laughter it's like the
most deepest the deepest most primal
feeling we have it
communicating feeling we have is is like
laughter mmm well obviously he cries
first lots of crying but but all you
were feeding him yeah but but ultimately
two weeks but but ultimately beyond that
it's laughter his feeding window was
closed yeah his feeding windows closed
when I need to be open big time his
feeling windows always open man he
gained a lot of weight though now he's a
bit eh uh he's a little food Pacino he's
fast
I mean he's chunky in a good way there's
something beautiful about right around
six months went kids you can still kind
of hold them they'll be really kind of
chill sometimes but they're just getting
so alive that it's like man there's
something real beautiful about that age
question John stainless has a question
here too good did we answer that other
question uh yeah um you it was about -
your favorite video and good day brother
I'm trying to get over there to
Australia maybe with another comedian
we're trying to partner up a package and
come back over there nice this John
Stamos his son Ethan man just wanted to
know if you ever plan on making any more
videos on your main channel or if you're
just focused on the podcast now because
we missed the main channel videos - so
anyway gang gang Papa bless this is a
appreciate that this is your last dude
that's gonna be the new show you know
yeah dangler
a recurring question we probably had
that about ten times yeah mom that's a
tough one to answer you know the truth
is by the way it's nice and everyone
likes me I have a feeling that most
people hate me really I do
yeah I'm so refreshed when people are
nice to me and care about me you know
what reminds me that I think you're a
neat person is that you are your ability
to that I just feel you're transparent
hmm your transparency reminds it's just
such a it's such a nice quality I feel
like you have oh thank you that I think
it's just like Oh immediately oh I know
at least I'm I'm gonna be able to be
very real with this person and there's
something that's very comfortable about
that I think for people because we don't
get that very much I think for me I
found it like I just think it's real
healthy you can't you don't want it like
that that could make you I mean that
makes me feel real bad at one point
that's like oh I'm assuming that
everyone out there hates me but at the
same time it's nice to be able to say
that you know it would levy
it alleviates the the pressure to be
able to say what that I think everyone
hates me something like that right you
know instead of holding that on it feels
real serious if you hold on to something
like that
yeah yeah to get it out that's a good
point yeah yes so many think we don't
realize it we have to get it out then
you got to get it out I try to get as
much out as I can yeah even little
things little resentments we have young
people that [ __ ] [ __ ] hides and oh
yeah an episode a bad yeah absolutely
when did they at line turn it to just
did it was it always just murders and
[ __ ] well the two most watched shows in
the entire world Joe Rogan Dateline is
Dateline that popular oh I believe that
there's not I believe the two most
consumed shows in the entire world and I
believe this wholeheartedly Oh Joe Rogan
and I've tried watching Dateline a
couple of times but I it just kind of
just feels like a poor man's like
Netflix series I was raised on it bro my
mother the first show we watched
together was America's most woman that
show was badass
she made me hold her hand when the parts
got scary and I was so [ __ ] scared
[ __ ] how old are you you need to convert
oh yes
Safford maybe did that show was badass
when I was a kid though that was a real
[ __ ] they were catching criminals [ __ ]
yeah
I was scary as [ __ ] those guys scared
the [ __ ] out of me all those criminals
man my main channel here's the thing I
feel like I'm in a new phase of my life
I feel like at a certain point those
videos were exciting they were fun they
were great to do it was fulfilling me in
every way but I feel like on not just on
YouTube but in myself personally that
those videos don't they don't fulfill me
anymore I find them to be I forced them
out and I have to pull my own teeth to
get the work done and although I know
people like it and frankly I like it to
the final product is always fun to look
at I just find that that um maybe that
life that part of my life is behind me
that being said I still have a studio in
my house that's ready to go if I ever
feel the need to make one of those
videos what I like it happen yeah I like
the idea of just making one off when I'm
real inspired to do it when something
comes up then I'm like honey make a
video about that but I just feel like
you know I've been I was doing that for
a long time and and I think it's time to
to just open a new chapter and just be
there because a lot of Tywin
I've been doing the podcast for a while
now and I feel like just now recently
since Theodore was born that I really
feel like I'm doing the podcast right
you know I was doing it but now I'm
really doing it yeah and I like that I
like that it's a new challenge I like
that it's testing of skills I like that
I'm working with other people that's
collaborative where if I'm making a
video it's all my shoulders and I feel
like I had a lot of resentment and
frustration from that mm-hmm
you know it's like it's also my [ __ ]
job like nobody can help me do this
I like collaborating with people you do
and in the case of the podcast it was at
first was very difficult for me but I
found that it's it's been fantastic like
we have three cast members that are back
there and they've become a big part of
the show that's and I think that it's I
think it's great I think it's a really
fun dynamic it's fun it's exciting it's
a new experience is testing new skills
and myself and I think um I'm following
that feeling that there's something else
out there for me to do now yeah it's
it's it's interesting man here you say
that it makes me think like so many
times I we often so many times it's it's
hard to move on it's hard to like I'm
really I'm really struggling recently
just you know I don't want to grow up I
just don't want to it's like what does
throwing up mean to you I think it means
like just like letting go your freedom
letting go I think I've always revolved
in such this kid space and myself mm-hmm
dad I don't really know how I am as an
adult hmm and that's very scary to me
hmm
like I'm good I'll do well as a kid like
I was a kid it wasn't the most fun a lot
of times but I [ __ ] did a good job of
it do you have like positive adult role
models in your life I don't know I mean
I Brendon from King in the sting but so
probably not really he's not I mean he's
your he's a good dad but he's your
contemporary yeah he's a muddy as a kid
looking up to an adult did you have any
positive adult role models no probably
not
me neither and I think that I wouldn't
do the same thing is that I I think a
lot of the anxiety and pressure I was
feeling too was kind of a a in a sense
not wanting to grow up hmm and and I
think the problem is that you never saw
an adult who was content and happy and
and you thought hey that's cool that's a
good thing that's something I wanted
Peter something I want to do is aging
gracefully and be more mature
Payne [ __ ] bills and having a kid and
you know what I mean all the things that
but for me that was all scary [ __ ] that
oh yeah he's so scary I associated with
negative things but it's you know but
yeah I think at some point yeah what
you're saying is that yet getting to a
place and then embracing it right
instead of living on both sides of the
fence and yeah you know it's inevitable
right so right yeah and also though I
think some of it is - it's like it's fun
to like still be young while I can
ya know young and not and you can it's
some things I can't do like I can't you
know you can't date some of these young
girls you have to go out and pretend
like you never [ __ ] like her - some
movies like you can't even mention any
movies you like because they've never
heard them and it's so [ __ ] scary to
just you mean like old movies or new
what do you movies yeah I feel old
oh that even when I'm in a conversation
if there's like a young you know like
you're not a young girl but I mean I
know g-man yeah I know what you mean
you're like [ __ ] dude I am an adult now
yeah it's happening and I need to get on
board with it how old are you I'm 39 man
I'm gonna don't you look youthful oh
thanks man yeah you look youthful thank
you you look younger the last time I saw
you maybe it's the haircut or maybe it's
the pills you know we definitely know
anything I don't know what I always look
older than I am real always people swim
I'm like 50 Oh what just I don't know if
that's good or bad but I think you it's
kind of funny I'm gonna live till I'm a
hundred but I'll die when I'm 60 yeah
you know what I mean weird type of
people think I'm like some weird lecture
on HeLa like I'm some dude who dates
outside his age by like a decade but I'm
like nah dude we're two years apart but
what were we talking come I agree it's
hard to move on and I think that maybe
want one of the one of my strengths
maybe is just knowing when it's time to
move on hmm certain points in my life
where I've just you know it's tough and
especially the fans are resistant to and
they make you question your own decision
to move on but ultimately you know
ultimately you'll know before they will
and so it's tough on you it's tough on
them
stuff on you because they don't want you
to move on but you know for yourself you
have to move on and they and you know
they they don't know that they don't
know what you feel they just want more
of the same
but the truth is these people will get
tired of the same [ __ ] too and then
they'll eventually leave and you're just
stuck in a rut doing the same stupid
[ __ ] song good dance you've been
doing for a decade and nobody's happy
anymore you most importantly aren't and
the fans don't care they don't they say
he's [ __ ] stale right yeah there's
you have to yet there's a there's a
gracious time to let you to eat to
evolve right now like a worm there's
only a worm you know I'm finally like
[ __ ] y'all and people are like oh this
[ __ ] war you're gonna quit being a
worm do you out of your mind is the best
[ __ ] weed moist out voices hog dude
is a rain coming tomorrow and he's like
oh yeah [ __ ] y'all brah they flies by
Lehman's I gotta leave when it's good
yeah you gotta leave when it's good
let's leave into one more question
that's come in what do we got Nick from
Frank Castillo it looked like something
came in what up Theo what upbeat then
this is Preston coming to you from
furniture Kentucky I got a quick
question for the vapenation guy over
there you know so far nuts into it if
you're a few months into being a dad
what you think been the most rewarding
part about being the dad and we look
forward to the most it's a little Fupa
Junior gets older fooling around they
have it let me know what y'all think
can't wait to hear from y'all love both
the old man y'all make a week so much
smoother so let me know yeah I love the
yells he's repping y'all's like Oh
molasses Frankfort Kentucky man Thank
You Spencer was his name yeah
thank you sir may be another step
another estin sorry press press and the
other Spencer first of all she never
would have guessed he was oppressed in
with you um probably not yeah
what if he's more like a I would have
guessed this man was a rum Romero maybe
look at him he's right there beautiful
young fella you got faith hair on his
face on the bottom of his beard I don't
know what his name is on Romel like I
see him as our Oh Mel Rome al mm-hmm
sometimes a karate instructor I'm with
you but thank you very much Preston
another person who apparently likes me
so that's nice did you get any hated me
no they were there were a ton that loved
you a lot so many inside jokes people
that they weren't really questions they
were just like you were farting into the
mic yeah but people were huge fans who
probably got 100 100 over a hundred
questions well that's nice thank you to
everyone who did that I appreciate that
the best thing about you know having
Theodore right now is he's just got this
beautiful smile
he's just when he's just expressing joy
it's a beautiful thing I can't wait to
talk to him I can't wait for him to be
able to sit up on his own to walk I
can't wait to communicate with him man
that's so exciting to me to be able to
know what he's thinking and what's going
on in there cuz he's a little person he
was marinating inside of there and I
can't wait to to know to know who he is
you know like a pinata almost kind of
we're right I don't I don't hit him with
the stick there's not candies inside I
don't want to kill no yeah but I but in
other ways he is I do want to hang him
from a tree no I don't do that I'm not
sure what in what ways he's like a
pinata yeah I don't know it's a colorful
colorful we decide yeah there it is
there you go
Nick a time right there um I can't wait
to do stuff cuz right now he he's still
very young yeah he can't do it very
walking really no that mine no but I'm
excited to like take him places to stuff
and let's go on you know tell them about
life film dad ship teaching about policy
probably yeah mm-hmm or Wiener in the
future there's what the one yeah that
talk I hope it doesn't come for a while
I'm not looking for to talk to him about
[ __ ] yeah but that day will come I'm
sure well you want to give him the talk
right now you and I can give it to him
together this is your dad from the past
yeah well Theodore Theodore there'll be
a time where and I'm just your dad's
friend it'll be a time where you'll have
to explain to your tier partner why your
penis is so small
just know that's my fault the micropenis
is my fault son but also let them know
that they it's doesn't really losing
their virginity doesn't count if it's a
micro penis right that doesn't count
you got a fist someone and you gotta go
elbow deep to lose your virginity am I
talking about noodling bro yeah that'd
be an Olympic sport by the end um Nick
anything else pertinent that you wanted
to hit I was a little curious if you're
like worried about him growing up like
with the how much you know about the
Internet and then as he gets older like
discovering stuff on his own or about me
or just on the Internet no just on the
Internet just who the Internet's [ __ ]
tariffs I don't know how these young
kids because me and you we grew up the
first time I saw a smartphone I was in
college yeah the first time I saw yeah
smartphone definite first time I had a
cell phone I was I was at 20 and so and
you know III am I'm scared I seem like
they're actually buh-burn and made a
great this great video about it our
movie about it eighth grade mmm-hmm it's
but I never thought about how these kids
grow up with Instagram and all these
social medias and these little [ __ ]
kids with smartphones in like you know
middle school and it's yeah it's scary
it terrifies me I don't I just I never
grew up with that so I almost don't know
how to relate to that that kind of
social pressure I know that like the
social pressures you feel just as a as a
as a prepubescent or in high school or
middle school is is you know already
stressful but the added stress of like
interacting with people on Instagram do
people like myself like me people are
like trashing on people on Instagram
there's like bowling on Instagram and
there's all these cliques the cyber
cliques and I mean it's it's it's scary
I hope that I can um I hope that I can
you know give give him guidance through
that because I I'm not sure what it's
like to grow up like that I think
keeping him hume and you know try and
keep him in human spaces you know where
he's revving real feelings and things
that are you know actual emotions and
stuff and not just reactions mmm
I think a lot of these kids are it's
just more reactive it seems
like the way that they live kind of with
electronics but yet I don't know like my
nice thought imagination was an app and
that really so crazy how what was the
context of that just like y'all say you
know your imagination he's like what do
you mean I was like use your imagination
really he's like I don't think we have
it I'll check my mom's phone and I was
like all right well yeah but that you
know that's not far off it's terrifying
and I'm afraid of like I mean it must
tear apart there I mean the self-esteem
you know you got to put pictures of
yourself online I mean when I was that
age I I couldn't look at photos of
myself I I it it would ruin my day to
see a photo of myself at that age yet
these kids got to put photos of
themselves online and try to compete
with like the handsome kids in their
school and [ __ ] you know it's it's it's
tough I don't know how these kids are
gonna grow up but do you think in the
end that it all equates back to exactly
the same way it was just the medium is a
little different now I'm starting to
probably more or less I mean when I I
mean more or less you know I think we
don't know them because the electronic
thing it is different there's this weird
other reflective surface in the world
that wasn't there when we were well you
know it's not all bad either
I mean you have a ton of knowledge at
your fingertips I think that I think
that it gives them certain coordinating
skills and you know I've read studies
like being in being in a 3d world can
kind of help your brain like playing
video games in a 3d world can enhance
your perception and why are your brain
in a different way that the for in a
good way really yeah because you you
because it's kind of a it's kind of a an
incredible task to be able to to
actualize a 3d space on a 2d monitor if
you're playing a video game and you're
wandering around and you're you're
you're really existing in this 3d world
but it's just on a screen I mean that
takes a lot of brain power I feel like
and a lot of educating just happens that
we enjoy it we like doing it but I think
that that definitely taps into some kind
of part of our brain that
that could be good I really do think so
I think a lot of that kind of stuff is
is over maybe over his alarmist stuff I
grew up playing video games you know
right yeah me too I loved him we played
it a ton I'm not worried about video
games so much as I am about the the
social pressure of being on Instagram
when at 12 yeah the social media was it
would definitely be different if there
was because at least whenever we left
home and stuff when we went home from
school and stuff that was Instagram
school was Instagram and it was gone
when she left there right right go home
and have a life outside of there that
was separate and it was and I looked in
the mirror a couple times a day and
that's when I saw myself it wasn't like
I'm trying to find good good angles I
think I represent myself and I rethought
about that yeah yet I got home to see
the mirror to even [ __ ] see yourself
you look like [ __ ] I only need to remind
myself I look like [ __ ] three times a
day not every time I put my phone yeah
it's tough and I don't know how I deal
with that as a young kid I'm I'm a
little bit worried about that but I'll
you know hopefully you'll navigate it
man
hopefully I did it right what can
Theodore's problem yeah that's true we
did it he's got to deal with the [ __ ]
world that's burning yeah and Instagram
you [ __ ] I'll be dead by I'll be dead
so it's his problem
look man any kid that for [ __ ] two
weeks is sucking on a dry tip bro I
[ __ ] respect he's a warrior
you'll be fine yeah that's a good point
Ethan thanks so much man mmm thank you
thank you for inviting happy for you bro
and I love uh I wish to be gotten to
maybe talk a little bit more about like
some of the mental health stuff but just
for my own well-being you know I was
it's hard to get into that it's hard to
find the right you can't always do it
the groove I'm here though you won't
keep talking oh it's up to you you
trying to end this obviously you're
trying to end this you got [ __ ] to do
your busy guy your busy guy I have
enough I just have an appointment at
4:00 p.m. what time is it oh you know
what we'll do your will do yours okay
this has been a you know there's been a
good experience sometimes for me it's
also about sometimes it's just like it's
easier than other times
mm-hmm I know exactly what you mean you
know mm-hmm it's just easier to like be
in a place um
I think even being as aghast sometimes
it's easier for me definitely like yes
that be and not a guess is all it for me
it's very tough sometimes
hmm but but do you inspired us to get
this office space good I love what you
guys did the space is incredible I don't
know if you ever showed a tour we have
we really just kind of finish buttoning
up like these these counters in this
control room were the last part so I do
I was gonna pitch that to you like
shooting like a crib style it's a good
idea the first time we've actually been
comfortably like had Nick in there where
it's we did it one other time but this
is it's really nice it's all just
evolving so but yeah I remember you
saying I think there's a space in our
building when I was here hmm on your
podcast yeah we're in the same building
did I use the bathroom before I had the
key already we did hear someone's coming
down the pipes yeah absolutely it was
definitely beautiful is like Africa no
you guys did an amazing job in here you
changed the carpet to a oh no they put
in new carpet for you guys yeah they had
some mannequins somebody was storing
mannequins in here which was lazy as
[ __ ] that's like a Doctor Who episode
and I wanted them I said keep our
mannequins were in at least two there
were two in the negotiations broke and
specifically with them
no they ended up taking them specific
ones they were like no way these are off
limits and I'm like what the [ __ ] like
okay sorry I didn't know you know huh
but it would definitely got interesting
with the [ __ ] it's interesting what
people do in the offices my kinfolk they
call them can [ __ ] your mannequin how do
you sexually identify i sexually
identify as a straight male mm-hm
by an area is that binary um I don't
know they embody all that he's binary
here yeah you're buying it yeah I'm your
moderator yeah I'm straight male I'm
doing women this time if maybe in next
reincarnation or two or three down the
road suck some dick I'm not gonna suck
it bro come on
I'll hold one outside but I'm not doing
anything indoors but I'll say this man
is that Trisha Paytas you guys had that
fair he's a real whole thing what was
going on she had nine different
ethnicities or genders and by the end I
didn't know what was going on she might
be and I literally looked in my pants to
see what was going on she's just a troll
I don't think she seemed like kind of
desperate to me yeah but she's also very
I do I love her well I want some / dance
as if someone was pretty entertaining
I agree she's very entertaining she'd
made this whole video about how she's um
identifies as a trans male even though
she looks like a female she dresses like
a female she even does born as a female
yeah she says you can be a lesbian and a
gay man at the same time I was like whoa
dude I'm like yeah I'm in like the lbgtq
zone right now
[ __ ] that I'm out brah see a pop I don't
go to Popeyes did you lose your life to
take a [ __ ] gun bruh I'll shoot
someone to death you know yeah dude I
went to Mardi Gras in New Orleans every
year we would go to the Popeyes and
watch people [ __ ] fight our people
where it goes down where it goes down
why is that no sandwiches I don't know I
want to see like one of the people but
what is it about I mean I had Popeyes
it's good that's a kill people for
Popeyes dude and shout out to my boy
[ __ ] John bruh Red John he works over
there paw paws off a highway 190 dude oh
yeah Popeyes was like a nice restaurant
when I was young
oh that was like or going out the pop by
son we get it and they had it came with
this little like figurine can you look
up the Popeyes a figurine toy that came
in there Happy Meal it was a little Axl
one of them on olive oil
Oh was actually Popeye and it came as an
Associated with Popeye yes
what was the spinach yeah and whatever
it was I had no idea there was
Association
it used to be associated with Popeye
should still be hmm like drop the
[ __ ] there it is the blue toy right
there click on that there we go they're
like you know what the chickens better
than pop nobody cares about Popeye you
could get spinach back in a day at
Popeyes
Wow I had no idea there was an
association they totally dropped the pot
pie from Popeyes and now it's just known
for mixed people [ __ ] body-slamming
more than the chicken Street fight
that's broke if Papa doesn't search the
sponsor the UFC that's a [ __ ] lost
opportunity I'm out man
Ethan Klein thank you so much give a big
hug your wife and congratulations I want
the adorn thank you very much that's
your name yeah it's a beautiful name man
and I'm happy to share with your son
blessings yeseo uh we see the issue
podcast at the we'll do it in the next
year
yep gang bless bro gang bless appreciate
it
[Music]
a little time for me to set that parking
brake
and let myself
[Music]